>> So well anyway, we do have some objects here today and how about this one
which is really cool coz it has moving parts, can you tell us about that? >> So
this is just a, its the basic claw sample and this actually, it's kind of funny,
this one comes with a machine when you buy it but the really cool thing about it
is. That when you design something like this, it used to be that you would
design something like this, send it overseas. Get a mold made and eventually
around three months in, send it back to you. It would cost you about $40,000 and
that's on the low scale. But now, I can design this in the afternoon, print it
that night on my at home 3D printer or take it to a service like Shapewaves or
any of those places. >> And have it back within a week for about you know,
anywhere between fifty to a hundred dollars. And I can see if things fit
together, I can see you know if there's thing that need slight adjustment before
I go into some sort of mass production, or maybe I don't even need mass
production, you know, it could just be for our home use. >> Is it just printed
as a single thing or did you snap it together or how's that work? >> Yeah, so
this one's really cool, it's actually printed as a single object. So what it
does is if you will, it just sits in a bed and the bed, think of like an ink jet
printer where a pad's coming over it. When that pads comes over the first time,
it puts little droplet's down to put that first layer. And on the way back it
hits it with an ultraviolet light which hardens that object, and then builds it
up with support material on the inside. The support material is water soluable.
>> So at the end of it when it all comes out I can then take it and wash it off
with a water pick and take all that support material out. Leaving me with a very
functional object. >> So support material is so that doesn't sag or what's,
what's support material about. >> Support material is, is just that. It's there
for moral support. It's there for to support the piece. So if you think about
inside of here, if you had to build something in space that was just going
across this plane, there's no way you could really do it because you can't build
on nothing. You can't just put something out into mid air, yet. And, but so
that's what we do is we actually put support material. Material in there for
this to build on top of and then we can rinse that out, so we can have things
with a giant cliff or you know, a weird angle at it, that you wouldn't normally
be able to just work your way up to layer by layer.